harvest funders asks what does hustle
look like for you now versus five or
even ten years ago why has it changed
this is such a great question thanks
harvest for it and I'm gonna expand on
it I'm gonna go long for him on I was
even talking to d-roc and Stephane that
this might have to turn into a three to
five minute video movie because I'm
starting to have this weird realization
I'm talking to Mike Trainor Mike about
this during the workouts which is like
wait a minute was I really hustling at
25 to 30 I wasn't in the email culture
yet nor was the wine industry nor was
Society the store closed at 9:00 you
know after a while 7:30 felt like the
appropriate time to leave you know I had
girlfriends that I lived with Brandon my
best friend who runs Wine Library lived
above me and like you know I can sit
here and think about you know 8:30 and
night on a Wednesday at 26 playing like
monopoly on GameCube and that is just
not even remotely close in the equation
at this point you know it's really fun
to be a businessman instead of an
athlete because your prime is so much
further down the path and you have so
much more time to get there right now
look athletes a lot of those people
those kids are you know jostling and
junior high in high school and so maybe
the timings a little bit different but
you know the truth is my hustle today
it's at an all-time high especially
since June 7th when I incorporated
working out which is driven me to wake
up so much earlier not that I have more
energy because I was high on sugar I've
come to realize but I you know I can
tell you this let's start with this
every person right here in this circle
this inner circle of five and and
anybody out there that really knows and
some of you have watched and I've thrown
up my calendar here and there nobody
comes close to me and really sniffs my
level of hustle and how much work I put
in and don't take a step back and saying
really because it is literally every
second of every minute of every day for
a very long period of time and you hear
about it
Alyx heard about it he was a fan
you knew when I was spitting through
this right he worked at vaynermedia but
until he got a little closer it gets
really intense it gets intense when I'm
working the way I'm working and I'm
texting 17 times on a Saturday while I'm
in the air and saying do this do this
and this and this I'm gonna do this and
this and this and this and this and this
and so my Hustle is up don't forget to
subscribe to my You Tube channel
you